leur carrière au cinéma débutait tout
juste mais il côtoyait déjà les plus
grands au festival de cannes deux
comédiens ont la vedette ce soir le
doyen 93 ans charles vanel est la
benjamine du cinéma français 14 ans
charlotte gainsbourg en 1986 à seulement
14 ans charlotte gainsbourg montait pour
la première fois les marches du palais
au même âge 27 ans plus tôt l'acteur
jean-pierre léaud foule est lui aussi le
tapis rouge pour la première fois aux
côtés de sa mère révélée par françois
truffaut l'adolescent incarnait le héros
turbulent du film les quatre cents coups
une collaboration sur laquelle il
revenait en 1965
tout ce que je trouve formidable dans
ses films enfin quand moi je
je travaille avec lui j'ai ce sentiment
de liberté de vérité et le sentiment de
vivre vraiment où la caméra en 1976
jodie foster avait-elle aussi 14 ans
pour sa première à cannes elle y défend
des le film taxi driver de martin
scorsese dans lequel elle incarnait une
prostituée le meilleur rôle que j'ai
fait dans ma vie j'ai trouvé cette
première fois que j'ai aimé ce que je
fais la même année isabelle adjani 20
ans présentait le film de roman polanski
le locataire dans lequel elle jouait le
rôle de stella
moi c'est plutôt un rush précipiter
puisque moi j'y suis arrivé hier pour
m'occuper de cette présentation avec
valence qui est
je dois dire que je n'ai le temps me de
voir un gros film rien du tout je
m'occupe uniquement de me promener d'une
caméra à l'autre comme ça neuf ans plus
tard en 1985 juliette binoche avait déjà
plusieurs films à son actif mais c'est
le long métrage rendez vous d'andré
téchiné qui la faisait venir à cannes
pour la première fois à 22 ans on est
vraiment votre carrière
je prendrai bien ouais je compte
beaucoup sur mon instinct je vois pas ma
carrière c'est les autres qui en parlent
en 1995 le film la haine de mathieu
kassovitz propulsait vincent cassel dans
la cour des grands infinie qu'il
défendrait vigoureusement pour sa
première expérience agréable bon en ce
qui me concerne ça a été ça a été la
première fois que je me retrouvais
impliqués à son prochain film où j'ai
compris ce que ça voulait dire de
travailler avant ça j'ai je faisais
l'acteur est là tout d'un coup on sait
bien travaillé de bon 24 ans plus tard
pour la 72e édition du festival vincent
cassel et de nous bourrer à cannes
l'acteur est à la fiche du film hors
norme du duo nakache toledano qui
clôturera le festival le 25 mai prochain
[Musique]